مرحبا يعطيكم العافيه معكم اخصائي في
التغذيه رزان الزيود من مدفع طبعا كلنا
بنعرف عن اهميه المعادن والفيتامينات
بالنسبه لجسم الانسان
[موسيقى]
الحديد طبعا كلنا بنعرف انه اذا صار عندنا
مشكله بالحديد او قلت كميه الحديد في جسم
الانسان انه راح يصير عندنا مشاكل بالهم
قلوبيين اللي بيوصل للدم وبيغدي لنا
الخلايا بالاكسجين خلونا نحكي عن مجموعه
المشاكل اللي بتصير معنا لما يكون عندنا
نقص في معدن الحديد في جسمنا راح يكون
عندنا تعب عام ارهاق صداع مستمر راح يصير
عن التساقط في الشعر راح يصير عنها زياده
في خفقان القلب وراح يصير في عندنا عدم
تركيز حتى لان الابر يعني المفروض احنا
نعاسي وجباتنا الغذائيه بمعنى الحديث
تجنبا هذه المشاكل خلينا نركز على معلومه
انه شرير بالشاي يعني مش بعت الغذائيه
بيخليني افطر بعدين الحقيقه فعلشان تجدني
بالنهايه المشكله انه انا ما استفيد من
الحديد وابتعد عن شريف تناول الشاي خلال
وجباتنا الغذائيه الثلاثه الرئيس الشاي
بحتب على مركب تلك اسد هذا المركب بتحد مع
الحديد اللي انا اخذتهم في وجبتي فبيكملوا
لنا مركب في المعده غير قابل الامتصاص
فبتكون انا ما استفدت من الحديد اللي
تناولته بوجبه الغذائي مصادر الحديد
الحيوانيه ونباتيه حيوانيه من اللحوم
الحمراء اللحوم البيضاء الاسماك والبيض
والحليب والمصادر النباتيه تيجي من
البقوليات والخضروات والفواكه
حابين نحكيها انه حمض المعده عندنا
بيحاولتنا ومركب الحديد من مركب غير قابل
للانتصاص له مركب قابل الامتصاص فالناس
اللي بياخذوا ادويه حموضه المعده راح يقل
عنهم نسبه امتصاص
[موسيقى]